on parle justement de ce sujet avec
notre invité par visioconférence Natalia
pousiref qui est normalement connecté ou
nous entendez bien
merci on vous entend également bonsoir
vous êtes donc la député renaissance de
la sixième circonscription des Yvelines
on parle avec vous dans un instant de
cette conférence des bagues vous
organisez à Saint-Germain-en-Laye sur la
thématique de la fin de vie mais
forcément le sujet du jour c'est aussi
cette réforme des retraites retraites le
texte est examiné depuis aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle par les députés alors
on avait eu une forte mobilisation le 31
janvier il y a un sondage aussi faible
qui est sorti hier qui fait état que 69%
des français serait contre la réforme et
le texte entre aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
nationale on le sait avec ces 20 000
amendements déposés par par l'opposition
d'émotions également de de rejet quel
était l'ambiance cet après-midi là quel
est l'ambiance au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale
nous sommes en train de lancer le débat
mais le démarrage a été difficile a été
très chahuté je veux dire puisqu'il y
avait des contestations des arguties
juridiques mais finalement nous allons
procéder à des
j'espère que
vous apaisé par
la suite c'est une semaine décisive pour
la majorité avec la
l'examen en première lecture de ce texte
vous l'abordez comment cette semaine
nous avons fait notre propre travail
d'amendement nous espérons seulement que
le débat aura lieu parce que en l'état
actuel des choses il y a 18000
amendements déposés par la nups et que
c'est de fonction caractérisée ça veut
dire que nous avons jusqu'au 17 février
nous ne sommes pas forcément
à même de d'examiner tout le texte
et ça c'est un regret parce que nous
nous avons construit quelques
amendements sur lequel nous aimerions
qui est un vrai débat et le débat de
puisse se dérouler dans le meilleur état
d'esprit dans le calme possible mais ce
n'est pas visiblement ce que vous avez
devoir retourner bientôt dans
l'hémicycle donc on va aborder le
deuxième sujet ce pour lequel vous êtes
celui pour lequel vous êtes venus nous
parler c'est donc ce cette conférence
débat qui est organisée ce jeudi à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la fin de vie
parlons-en ensemble c'est à la salle
Jacques Tati le début de la conférence
est fixée à 19h30 on va peut-être
pouvoir avoir une animation s'afficher
pour avoir toutes les informations et ce
sera en présence de la ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé Agnès Firmin le
Bodo de députés également et aussi de
représentants du monde médical et
associatif on précise juste qu'il y a en
ce moment toute une réflexion autour de
la fin de vie à une compréhension une
convention citoyenne qui réunit 150
français et qui planchent sur le sujet
et qui doit rendre ses conclusions en
mars c'est le président de la République
a parlé aussi d'une nouvelle législation
qui pourrait voir le jour d'ici la fin
2023 pourquoi organiser cette conférence
des bas Natalia pouzirev c'est pour
nourrir le débat justement au niveau
départemental au niveau régional
absolument pour nourrir le débat et
j'espère que nous pourrons d'ailleurs
faire un compte rendu et le remonter à
la ministre directement qui sera là mais
c'est aussi parce que j'ai été
interpellé très régulièrement sur le
sujet c'est une question qui intéresse
les habitants de la circonscription je
pense que effectivement nous sommes tous
confrontés
au sujet de la fin de vie d'un proche ou
à se poser des questions en ce qui nous
concerne et donc ce débat doit répondre
à une attente il doit être je pense
permettre de voir tous les aspects de la
question moi j'ai connu à ce qui est un
philosophe qui soit là plus éclairé
c'est des questions d'éthique il y aura
aussi
l'ancien député classe qui représente le
commissaire Conseil national d'éthique
qui était porteur de la loi classe
Leonetti qui fait
référence aujourd'hui on verra donc avec
ces représentants ainsi que des
représentants de l'association ADMD qui
prône le droit de mourir dans la dignité
ainsi qu'avec la le corps médical qui
sera présent également on verra s'il y a
d'autres équilibres à trouver des
évolutions envisagées à cette voix en
tout cas nous sommes nous sommes pour
accueillir tous les publics qui
s'intéressent à cette question qui vient
et forcément universel évolution ou pas
de cette loi statu quo on le précise
dans la loi clef Leonetti interdit
l'euthanasier le suicide assisté
aujourd'hui c'est la loi qui est en
vigueur vous le disiez on peut aller
vers une évolution mais mais tout est
ouvert parce que Emmanuel Macron disait
avant l'élection présidentielle vouloir
aller au-delà peut-être sur le modèle
belge et dépénalisé le tanasie
finalement avant de dire qu'il y avait
pas forcément un modèle qui prédominait
tout est ouvert aujourd'hui encore
absolument tout est ouvert parce que je
crois qu'il faut avoir la parole des
experts aussi c'est pour ça que à lors
de ce débat il y aura aussi une
psychologue et une infirmière des soins
palliatifs donc les personnes qui ont
justement
le patient en fin de vie et il y a aussi
des questions légitimes que se posent la
population sur ses droits sa liberté de
pouvoir décider de sa fin de vie donc je
crois que ça reste très ouvert et il y a
des cas particuliers comme par exemple
la maladie Sherco faut savoir comment on
peut traiter ces cas très graves qui qui
plongent les malades dans une grande
douleur et sans pouvoir agir sur leur
propre destin et enfin je pense qu'une
question déjà évidentes c'est d'avoir
des palliatifs qu'ils soient
dotés et répartis également sur le
territoire car en tout cas il ne peut
pas y avoir d'inégalités
soins palliatifs ce n'est plus possible
aujourd'hui dans la France si on veut
pouvoir accompagner dignement
les personnes
et vous l'avez dit aussi l'objectif
c'est de faire remonter les conclusions
tout ce qui va être dit au cours de
cette soirée l'idée c'est de pouvoir les
faire remonter
absolument moi je pense que nous aurons
un compte-rendu qui sera disponible
en sortie de débat avec quelques
remarques pertinentes on ne va pas
tourner mais j'espère que les échanges
croisés d'enrichir le débat et comme la
ministre sera présente elle aura donc
ces éléments de réflexion
merci Nathalie on va vous laisser
retourner dans l'hémicycle on le disait
avec une semaine chargée pour pour la
majorité et le début de l'examen dans
l'hémicycle leur semblait national par
les députés de ce projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites merci d'avoir été
avec nous
merci à vous donc c'est jeudi 9 février
19h30 salle Jacques Tati
Saint-Germain-en-Laye merci voilà on le
rappelle on va voir peut-être une
nouvelle fois l'animation s'afficher
pour toutes les informations avec donc
cette conférence débat sur la fin de vie
ce sera jeudi à 19h30 à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye salle et Jacques
Tati pour retrouver le lien
d'inscription on se rend directement sur
les comptes Facebook et Twitter de
Natalia pouzireff je le rappelle député
de la sixième circonscription des
Yvelines qui était avec nous